Film Courage: Elaine, do you remember the
first time you heard about [the idea for]
SPACE COMMAND [Movie]?
Elaine Zicree: Oh, my gosh!
Marc Zicree: [Laughs] Elaine Zicree: Well…no
I don’t.
It seems to be ubiquitous.
Marc Zicree: …It’s the hell you wondered
into [smiling].
Elaine Zicree: …He [Marc] has been talking
about it forever, you know?
But I actually don’t remember.
When did you first hit me up with that [laughing]?
Marc Zicree: Hhmmm??
Well you know it’s funny because with SPACE
COMMAND it evolved over a period of time.
Basically as I said Star Trek was really a
formative moment in my life.
When Star Trek debuted the first episode was
The Man Trap.
It aired….I think Star Trek debuted when
I was 10 years old and it was the thing I
had been waiting all my life for it.
It really brought everything together.
And I think from the moment that I read The
Making of Star Trek when I was 13, I decided
I wanted to be a show runner.
I wanted to create and run my own science
fiction show.
And all the hundred of hours of television
I did.
All the books I wrote were all toward learning
that, gaining those skills that I would need
to be able to do that thing.
And when Elaine and I got together…we’ve
been together for 40 years.
We’ve been married for 39 [years].
She was a terrific director.
She’d already been a director for an off-broadway
show.
She’d already been an actress.
She was a wonderful writer and so on some
projects we would collaborate and on other
projects we would work more individually over
the years.
But clearly with SPACE COMMAND it obvious
that I would need her skill set.
And we both love working with actors.
We both love working with editors.
I love visual effects artists.
I love concept designers and so forth.
So I had been gathering a team.
So from the beginning I knew that I wanted
to work with Elaine on this project.
Elaine Zicree: The key jumping off point was
we were both feeling disturbed about the dark
and cynical turn that science fiction had
taken and he [Marc] introduced me…I guess
I knew a little bit about it before, but he
was a great fan of things like Space Patrol
and it was where bad things happen but the
good people were good people.
Marc Zicree: Well…just to jump in for a
second, Space Patrol was a show that aired
live in the 1950’s.
And I didn't grow up watching it but in the
1980’s USA Cable [Network] had a show called
Night Flight and they ran kinescopes of that
show.
Kinescopes were filmed…basically you’d
put a camera, a 16 mm camera on a high-resolution
TV screen as the show was broadcast live and
you would record it on film and that was called
kinescopes.
And so they would air those kinescopes of
Space Patrol.
It was a wonderful show.
It came on before Star Trek.
But it had a great sense of adventure and
later I met the start of the show Ed Kemmer
who had been a pilot in World War II.
He flew a (North American Aviation) P-51 Mustang.
He was captured by the Germans.
Escaped from a German prisoner-of-war camp.
He was a real hero before he played a science
fiction hero in the 1950’s.
Elaine Zicree: And he looked like one.
He seemed like one.
Marc Zicree: A very handsome man.
And so that was part of the inspiration and
then of course Star Trek.
And what Elaine was talking about [regarding]
the dark science fiction, there was a period
a few years ago where all the science fiction
was very dark and very dystopic, whether it
was Battlestar Galactica which I very much
liked or Elysium or After Earth or any of
these things.
They all were saying “The future is going
to be really bad and there is not anything
you can do about it.”
Elaine Zicree: And that most people are mean-spirited
and things don’t work out.
And what was odd and what Marc pointed out
that was odd, these were written by writers
whose lives were pretty darn good.
Marc Zicree: Yeah, they would go home to their
families and they lived in Pacific Palisades.
It was a very nice life.
They were paid hundred of thousands of dollars
or millions of dollars.
So some how there was a disconnect from the
life they were creating personally and the
work they were writing.
And I felt very strongly that science fiction,
Outer Limits, Twilight Zone, Star Trek, those
shows had a moral compass.
And particularly Star Trek said “The future
is going to have challenges.”
Star Trek was shot during the civil rights
movement, during the Vietnam War and yet said
“The future is going to have challenges
but we can reach across boundaries and barriers
and come together to create something better.”
And I thought that was very important to say
now.
Elaine Zicree: And some of it is not just
about science fiction, it’s the objective
of storytelling.
I mean if we assume that most people have
kind of a hard life, that somebody in their
family is mentally ill, somebody is on substances.
You struggle and you work hard and you watch
a story and it says “Well things are really
dark and awful and you don’t have any hope
and things are going to go to hell.”
And you say well is that really a responsible
stand to take or do you want your audience
to go out of there and say “Okay, it’s
a struggle but people can come out on top.
People are basically good at heart if you
just give them a shot.”
And you give people a sense when they leave
that theater there is possibility.
It just seems far more accurate and socially
responsible then to just put them on a downer.
Marc Zicree: Well, you know, we’re working
in an extremely powerful medium.
Television reaches millions of people around
the world.
If you do it right, it lasts forever.
Most of the shows I’ve written for are still
being watched even the ones I wrote when I
was in my early twenties.
And so there is a question that many writers
never ask themselves, which is (as far as
I can tell)… which is “Am I actually creating
something which is making the world a better
place?
Am I actually sending out a message that I
would want people to take to heart?”
You know TV can do one of three things: It
can anesthetize or fill people with despair
or inspire people.
And I think the first obligation of any dramatic
entertainment is to entertain, obviously.
If you don’t entertain, it doesn’t matter
what your message is.
People won’t stick around for it.
But beyond that, once you entertain people,
once you bring them into your world and they
love that world and want to be part of that
world, then if you can say take these lessons,
take what you’ve seen in this story, take
it out into the real world, take it out into
your life, you can actually have a better
life.
You can actually make a better world.
I think those are very important messages
to communicate.
Elaine Zicree: Not airy-fairy.
Not to sugar coat anything.
Because people don’t like to be lied to.
And they know when they’re being lied to
like “Oh, everybody is happy and everybody
is…” but within a real context where you
say “Okay, things are hard, you get into
a bad mood, you say the wrong thing but you
can be man enough to apologize.”
Those are the kind of things you’d like
to address.
Question for the Viewers: Do you feel a responsibility
to inspire with your writing/storytelling?